I think the one thing that business
casual turns out to be difficult for a
lot of guys is they hear the word casual
so they think that suddenly that means
sloppy and I have to say even if you're
in jeans if it's a polished fit if it's
not overly washed on the denim and also
you can always think about one piece
that connotates something more formal
whether it's a knit tie or a button-down
shirt that kind of attitude is going to
give you that perfect blend of something
that's polished and authoritative but at
the same time still casual guess what
accessories count think about a really
great fold watch think about a belt that
has a little more personality I think
those are the things that separate you
from the pack the big thing you have to
remember about jeans at the office no
holes no tears keep it dark keep it trim
when you think about dressing down a
suit think about a turtleneck or a
crewneck whether it's a lightweight
sweater can be a t-shirt any of those
pieces popped underneath your jacket
worn back to a pair of jeans it can take
you anywhere in the world you know what
chinos are great jeans are great but
chinos with a saggy butt and a big leg
sorry
dad's in town you want to look trim and
slim so whatever it is keep it trimmed
keep it slim and you know what that
works on every size man
you